police timeline shows the gunman carried
out the deadliest school shooting in
Florida history in about seven minutes
suspect Nicholas Cruz made his first
court appearance yesterday by video one
of the victims who will be buried today
is 14 year-old Alyssa Salah death her
mother Lori had an emotional message for
President Trump yesterday the gunman a
crazy person just walks right into the
window of my child's door you say oh
there's a holiday played on a local
soccer team her parents were seen crying
and hugging players and coaches on the
soccer field yesterday a coach described
Alyssa as a bright funny kid and a true
leader I feel for her I do to you I know
her pain and her anger and that anger is
a good thing to have to it is nor people
have to see that yeah people have to see
it and feel it and understand it and I'm
thinking maybe it's different this time
I say this every time but maybe it is
different this time I'm hoping so people
should not have assault rifles unless
you're wearing some kind of uniform
certainly not at 18 19 years I think
parents are gonna make sure that
something gets done it's a not if not
they can't do it in Washington they're
gonna try and do something in Florida
yeah